[音楽]
2023年始まりましたさあここで問題
ですお正月は何日まででしょうかまあ1月
3日とかも言われてます1月10日とかも
言われてますはいいつまでがお正月になる
でしょうか僕ちょっとよくわからないん
ですけどもはい
えー
俺の中では5月までですというわけでお
正月といえばそう
ぼっちお正月おせち料理とかお雑煮とかお
餅とか食べると思うんですけどもお餅皆
さん食べられましたでしょうか僕は食べて
ません今回そんなお正月にぴったりいやお
正月関係ないお正月関係ないいつ食べても
美味しいんじゃないかというとんでもない
メニューを私見つけてしまいました僕が
見つけたというよりネットに乗ってたやつ
をそのままパクらせていただきます失礼
いたします俺の人生生きてきた経験値を
これは間違いなく美味しいです
必要なものお餅通り6pチーズ
以上で衝撃でしょこの3つだけでできて
しまうんです皆さんは知ってますか6p
チーズの美味しさこれはね
もう半分薬安価で決まれるこういう形の
チーズが6ピース入ってるんですけども
これがもうそのまま食べてもいいし
案件ではございません
全く個人で今回やらせてもらってますので
リアルな感想を皆様にお届けしたいと思い
ますまあ普通に食べても美味しいんですよ
うんうん
絶対クリーミー6BG以上使ったアレンジ
レシピってめちゃくちゃ美味しくてこれ昔
やったんですけどご飯に6ピーチーズの
ぶっこんで炊飯器で炊くとめっちゃ
美味しくなったんで
[音楽]
美味しいんですよねはい
入れますよしあと炊きます
[音楽]
ただ今回すごいなんかこれ公式さんが言っ
てらっしゃいますこちらのツイート610
公式さんからです作り方
え
乗りの上にお餅を乗せる
レンジで30秒チンそのように6匹地図を
乗せてさらにレンジで15秒チンという
わけで旅し的には強い美味しいときで旅
過ぎには強い美味しいときで旅過ぎには
強いいっちゃいましたね
ここに貼ってますよハードルが盛り上がっ
てしまいました皆さん
甲子園が欲しすぎてちょっと今
楽しみというわけでお正月気分ということ
でちょっとお餅を使って僕ぴーチーズの
アレンジレシピ作ってみたいと思いますで
は行こう
[音楽]
さあキッチンに着きました早速やっていき
たいと思いますまずは
てかこれサルでもできるな
まずは乗りを準備しますお餅載せます
消しゴム
本当にこんなんでいいのかこれでいいのか
本当にこんなんでで美味しいのかなんか
簡単すぎてめっちゃ不安なんですけど今
これを電子レンジで30秒チンします
[音楽]
17あ待って待ってあーやばいちょちょ
待ってこれもうやめていいもうやめていい
かな待って30秒も待ってないって30秒
待ってないよこれ30秒待ってやばいこれ
本当に30秒もう30秒経ったかね立った
よね止めます止めますこれちょっとやばい
あーこれ30秒もチンできないよなんか
溶けちゃったもん
あとは簡単6pチーズをここに乗せるだけ
あとは電子レンジで15秒チンで結構爆発
する感じでしたけども大丈夫かなえ15位
も大丈夫行きますスタート
怖い
無理
91011あやばい
落ちる出た
チーズがもう持てない
もうやばいおい
めちゃくちゃやんもうめちゃくちゃやって
それちょっと待ってくださいもう
めちゃくちゃですけど
餅が膨らんじゃってチーズが転がっちゃっ
てますねこれ
ええなんかさちょっとすいません画像拝借
させていただくんですけども公式さん的に
はこういう感じでなんか負け
るっぽいんですよね
多分なんとか形整えればいけそうな気は
するあもうチーズもとろとろですすごい
あーなんとか粘りましたこれを
これをこう包めば
甘い
完成えっと
完成ですお持ちトロッピーです
完成しました
美味しそうだなこれ猫舌の人と多分厳しい
です
ただ間違いなく6pチーズのクビみたいな
感じとお餅のとろとろが相まって美味しい
はずですいただきます
[音楽]
赤ちょっと待ってくれよこれ
ちょっと待ってくださいねお餅トラッピー
を食べ終わったカレーはおもむろに海苔を
取り出し2つ目のお餅ドロップを作り出し
たのであった
彼はもうお持ちドロッピーの虜になって
しまったのだもう誰も彼は止められないが
温度は2つ目はかなり見栄えが良くて
チョキ2回目は割としっかりできました
これ乗り2枚くらいの方がいいかもしれ
ないですねはみ出ちゃうお餅が爆発病って
なっちゃっていただきます
[音楽]
飛ぶぞこれいやなんかさすが公式さんが
美味しいって言ってるだけありますこれ
マジで美味しい何だろうなんでそのお餅の
なんかマイルドさと6pチーズのちょっと
強みの地図感がめっちゃ噛み合っててで
そこをノリがこうぐるっとラッピングし
てる感じで整えてるというか3つの食材の
バランスが完璧に合ってますいやうまい
うんこれごちそうさまでした
もちろんただお持つドロップを作るわけで
はありませんちょっと改良したはじめしゃ
ちょー専用はじめしゃちょーもちトラ
ハッピーインフィニティ作りたいと思い
ますまず
海苔をなるべく敷き詰めますできればお
持ちがこぼれないようにこんな感じにし
とく棚を用意ですねで次にお餅を浴びたけ
のせますもちろん乗せすぎると作品になる
のでまあ俺もバカじゃないので4つぐらい
かなあと
6pチーズを皆さんの思いの丈分皆さんが
6ページに食べたいって思う分だけに乗せ
てくださいこれぐらいですかねまあこの約
6pチーズ乗せていきましょうあとはこれ
をね
行けまあ30秒ぐらいでいいんじゃね
[音楽]
うんいいのではないでしょうかなんか曇っ
てきてるの
さあついについに完成してしまったただ
温度の方はこれが今後のお正月の定番に
なること間違いなし頑張って孫としてい
ますこれは負けるのか負けないのかあ無理
無理なのか無理なのかあこれ無理だ無理だ
完成です完成してしまいましたこちらが
はじめしゃちょー直伝持ちトロハッピー
インフィニティカロリー爆発的悪魔的
ワガママしっくやばい
食べ方わからん
[音楽]
うめえ
うまい
うまいうまった
[音楽]